(Lobby chatter)
(Phone ringing)
Cherry:
I'm 23 years old and...
(Desk bell ringing)
Cherry:
...sometimes I wonder if life
was wasted on me?
♪♪
Cherry:
I take all the beautiful things
to heart.
♪♪
Cherry:
Til I about die from it.
(Clicking)
♪ If I could save time in a
bottle ♪
♪ The first thing ♪
Cherry:
Hey, I'm really happy you're here.
Emily:
Why's that?
Cause I like you.
♪ But there never seems to be
enough time to do ♪
You're it for me.
I feel the same way.
Cherry:
I joined the army.
Emily:
Why would you do that?
Cherry:
Sometimes I feel like I've
already seen everything that's gonna happen.
♪♪
(click sound, pill sound and
money machine sound)
(Police sirens)
(Smashing sound)
Cherry:
And it's a nightmare.
♪♪
(Argh)
(Heavy breathing)
♪♪
Cherry:
My one true accomplishment was
not dying.
♪♪
Army man:
Move, back up!
I have this noise in my head.
It'll stop.
Emily:
One day it will go quiet.
Cherry:
I don't imagine that anyone goes
in for a robbery
Cherry:
if they're not in some
kind of desperation.
Cherry:
I've been at this a while now,
and it's no secret what my face
looks like.
(Gun shot) (Alarm sounds)
-Get on the ground!
Cherry:
The one thing about robbing
banks is you're mostly robbing women.
Cherry:
So the last thing you
want to be is rude.
Ma'am, it's nothing personal.
♪ There never seems to be enough
time ♪
♪ To do the things I want to
do, once you find them ♪
♪ Once you find them ♪
You're gonna make it through
this.
Emily:
I love you.
Cherry:
Can you look back to when you
met the one you love the most.
♪ Through time with ♪
Cherry:
And remember exactly how it was.
♪ Through time with ♪
Cherry:
What you saw in her that made
you say yes.
Cherry:
This is what I came here for.
(Screaming)
Cherry:
Sometimes I feel like I've
already seen everything that's gonna happen.
(Clink)
Cherry:
And it's a nightmare.
♪♪